talking and then the moment they finish
the song i was like my god yeah everyone
starts it's starting
and then they start playing the next
thing oh my god
they're all waiting for we're waiting
for city to shoot yeah yeah yeah and
even i'm like i'm standing up here i'm
like what am i from what's my [ __ ]
role
again it was like it was seeing you
nervous that made everyone else in the
room nervous right being like oh [ __ ]
this is actually finally happening right
and then the quartet stops for the final
time and then it's like everyone was
like okay it's starting right and then
sydney walks down and then you
immediately start breaking
and then
which i fully expected right so i'm just
like oh here come the floodgates
okay so it comes and then what stopped
me yeah was the song you guys yeah
i was just like oh my god here we go
is that god's thing
and i i literally like jan was sitting
next to me and i was sitting next to me
yeah and we all looked at each other
we're like that that's guts's theme
right yeah yeah so like okay so what
made you yeah that's what i wanted to
talk about what made you choose sydney
walked down the aisle to gutsy's theme
yeah and i i i which is amazing yeah
yeah which like i knew it was coming
because like i remember it was literally
the day that miura passed away right and
i remember you know we were we're at
netflix shoot at the day so i didn't
have like properly proper time to like
process that news
and i remember that day i went back home
and i put on guts's theme and i was just
like just like zoning out together this
thing [ __ ] crying
to the news that i just got announced
and
and you know sydney also
cindy was also listening to it just
listening to it uh seeing me listen to
it for hours yeah and she's just like i
[ __ ] [ __ ] love this song you know
yeah because like it's like to me gus's
theme is like
by far like one of one of the greatest
tracks in anime to like to like ever to
like ever be made you know it's it's
such a like a beautiful track and you
know it's unfortunate that it's been
memed a lot nowadays so that's that's
like that's like a lot of that's like
how people perceive guts's theme but
like
i remembered listening to that on that
day that it's just such a beautiful
[ __ ] track gorgeous yeah and i
[ __ ] cried to it so many times and so
i remember sydney goes to me
jokingly she turns to me and she was
like
wouldn't it be funny if we walked down
the aisle to this
and i was just like
yeah that'd be funny
and then we both turned to each other
and and we looked at each other in the
eyes and we're just like but what if
what are we gonna do we'll use the
[ __ ] default music yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then like we we like we're
like would it be would it be cheesy i
thought it would it would be cheesy and
so we let it we let it sink for a while
and like we let it sit for a few days we
let it sit for a few weeks and then like
the longer
the longer like we sat in it the more it
felt like it was just the right idea
because like i [ __ ] knew that i was
going to cry listening to god's theme
walking
like i'm sure if like people knew we
were going to play gus's theme that
would that would have taken like the
[ __ ]
thing yeah you know i i wish i knew
beforehand yeah yeah because i feel like
it was for me it was like the initial
like
really yeah it was like that moment
right it's like wow they're actually
using godzilla yeah like there was a
split second where i i was about to
start laughing yeah but then i was like
but then again seeing you and then
seeing sydney i was just like
nah this is like this is the right
choice yeah yeah yeah because it's like
i remember sydney was telling me that
you know before sydney comes out all the
bridesmaids walk out yeah so
if you are familiar with guts's theme
there's like the intro bit and then
there's like the voice there's the voice
of the guy going
and i remember thinking i see all the
bridesmaids walk out and i'm like
where's sydney where's sydney
and as soon as like the [ __ ]
comes up she's she just appears right
and apparently behind the scenes like
like sydney's like with her dad waiting
to walk out and her dad's like it's time
to go and she's like no i need to wait
for that moment in the right moment i
need to wait for that voice
before i appear
oh my god
it was like so incredibly well timed it
was incredibly wonderful i thought it
was just like [ __ ]
gorgeous but no sydney was like no i'm
waiting for this moment i i'm waiting
for you to get one shot yeah i didn't
[ __ ] work yeah i'm like i think
that's why i just immediately started
bawling because i hear i hear that voice
like just pop off and i see sydney
emerge i'm just like this is
it is it's a double whammy it's it's
it's like a [ __ ] beautiful slime i
can't i can't i cannot even begin to
describe
what i felt at that moment because it
was literally like a scene out of an
anime you know it was just kind of like
it was so like a final episode
yeah yeah yeah like like that moment
that that [ __ ] voice hit she emerges
and i'm
[ __ ]
i'm i'm like i'm like [ __ ] getting
teary-eyed just like [ __ ] thinking
about it but yeah she she walks down uh
we say our vows and we like i we [ __ ]
stumble through our [ __ ] house
you guys were like you guys were tearing
up obviously but like i think yeah you
guys so i would say
i say you take pauses but yeah yeah yeah
you took it yeah you took your time with
it okay yeah
you know it's not one of our [ __ ]
sponsors which is by the way
do you want to talk about the the actual
stumble now okay so
which is the greatest moment of this
wedding so obviously everyone's [ __ ]
sniffing everyone's crying after we've
just finished our vows together like
everyone's everyone's very emotional
everyone's saying it's a very emotional
just good vibes everyone's just happy
and so the registrar comes over and she
starts to say like the official vows
that we need to repeat after her in
order to in order to officialize our
marriage
and then she goes like
and then she goes like
uh she said my name like a few times
before so she knows how to pronounce my
name correctly and everything like that
and then it gets like the final vowels
where she goes most importantly yeah the
when she goes do you
grant god
[Music]
everyone in the room was like
i did it and that just like all of like
the nervousness and the like
like emotions just like [ __ ]
evaporated the entire room explodes and
like [ __ ] starts like
you wouldn't thought it was like a fifa
match
[Music]
it was
like like
it was so [ __ ] perfect that everyone
everybody thought it was scripted
everyone thought it was scripted yeah
and you and everyone was like you made
her say that right yeah
it was a bit it was a bit and i'm just
like no
that just makes it even better oh yeah
and i can't remember what i said after
that happened but i was like yeah
got him daddy
she did the thing she did the thing and
i'm like damn are you a trash taste
viewer because you just you just gave us
like a year's worth of content man she's
like this marriage
yeah i mean that that was that was a
brilliant moment that that was like the
icing on the cake yeah a lot of people
would be pissed off you know if their
name got mispronounced at the at that
wedding but i was just like i was just
like this this just this just like made
the wedding ten times more memorable at
that moment ten times more special and i
guess like yeah as you were saying like
the nerves just immediately like
disappeared yeah yeah yeah the rest of
the night was just good times yeah i i
did
almost [ __ ] up so close to [ __ ] up
and one of the most important moments of
my life because we finish our vows we're
officially well officially we're like
husband and wife yeah and then i go sit
down to sign my marriage papers and my
my
my marriage was a week after mcm right
so
like the previous week i had just been
like signing my [ __ ] i've just been
signing like hundreds and hundreds of
prints and everything like that but i
was signing them as gigguk right yeah of
course and like
like my my gig signature is very very
similar to my real signature but except
it spells out my real name right yeah
um and so what happens is
i sit down to sign my marriage
certificate i put down the g
and then i put down the i
guess
luckily like i stopped myself before
like i go too far but i like i get like
a fifth of the way to signing gigguk on
my marriage certificate
that would have been amazing you could
make the a from the eye right
vertical area yeah
you can recover from that yeah yeah yeah
but luckily i was able to recover from
that before i put down the extra g yeah
but were you just like sydney ponyways
yeah i said i nearly made a big mistake
i'm nearly married the wrong person yeah
i'm wearing giggles yeah i said sydney's
almost married to [ __ ] gigan
might as well just put down the [ __ ]
anime zone i just got a flashback i
remember when uh you know the whole the
[ __ ] spiel of uh if anybody has
anything to yeah yeah and sydney was
like don't you [ __ ] dare everywhere
that was good i like that part yeah yeah
because we were planning beforehand in
in the in the the boys locker room yeah
right or not the locker room but like
the changing room
the groomsmen and like all the all the
all the dudes were hanging out
we were like conspired to be like what
if we just like when when the when the
pastor says like you know if anyone
objects to this wedding please you know
say your piece right now whatever we
were all planning like all the boys to
just stand up and be like we have jeff
and then we just skip
out
like with the boys yeah we're like that
would have been funny yeah but but then
cindy was just like don't you [ __ ]
[ __ ] she verbally said that yeah
and everyone laughed it was it was it
was a great time and then yeah i just it
just felt like after that everyone was
just on such a high like it already felt
like everyone was drunk you know but
just like drunk on happiness drunk with
like good vibes and then alcohol and
then now they're like doubly drunk on
top of that so like they're like i mean
there was there was a lot of magical
things that happened at the wedding i
remember so we were taking we had some
[ __ ] excellent photographers and
videographers you know they were great
yeah they were [ __ ] great and then i
remember we we went outside we started
taking like photos and everything uh you
know with like the group photos family
photos and everything like that
and then
um and then we finally have like a
moment to ourselves and joey turns to me
and he goes wouldn't it be funny if we
did like the end of ava congratulations
scene right now and i i looked at you i
looked at joey and i look around and i'm
just i just realized this is like a once
in a lifetime time
this is literally a once in a lifetime
opportunity i'm like joey that's a great
[ __ ] idea
and
yeah yeah i literally gather the boys
because it's like you're like lads
assembled actually no it was it was
really funny because before that because
we we had like separate uh well while we
were taking photos like we
we had you know separate photos like the
guys and like the girls and oh my god
like the guys
the guys had so much [ __ ]
testosterone when we when we took our
photos i can't wait to see them but i
remember there was this really funny
moment where it was like a school
playground again where like all of the
girls were on one side of the venue and
all of the guys were on the other side
of the venue so it was it was it was
like a school trip or something so
luckily all of the guys were gathered in
one spot and i like i like i like gather
the boys i like i it's
we have an important mission lads okay
and at this point people people are like
people like gum why are you calling us
we're just taking the photos yeah i'm
like and i'm like
has everyone seen evangelion and
immediately as soon as i say that
everyone's like
king we know what to do say no more
say no walking we know exactly what to
do which is the beauty of like having
like a bunch of like weebs as friends
right because everyone's just on the
same page yeah i didn't even need to say
what we did yeah and so we filmed the uh
congratulations scene that's [ __ ]
amazing about amazing yeah yeah it came
out maybe you did it
congratulations
thank you
[Music]